This Valentine’s Day,
revisit the film that reminds you that no
matter how much you love each other
you’re both gonna grow old and die.
The Notebook.
From sappy author Nicholas Sparks, comes the
timeless romance that paved the way for millions
of people to form unrealistic expectations
of their real-life relationships.
Meet Allie, an attractive, wealthy, Southern
Belle who’s biggest problem is that everyone
adores her.
Meet Noah, a poor country boy who’s entire
family is dead.
When these two find each other, he’ll criticize
her for being a pushover, and then constantly
tell her what to do.
"Get in the water!
Get in!"
And she’ll abandon him on numerous occasions.
Together they’ll be so indecisive, you’ll
wonder why they’re even trying.
"I love you."
"I love him!"
"I hate you!
I hate you!"
"I love him!"
"Now I hate you!"
"I need you to tell him that I love him."
"If you leave here, I hate you."
"Do you guys love each other?"
"Look at us: we're already fighting!"
"Well, that's what we do!"
A love.
that taught an entire generation of women,
that it's perfectly okay to string along a
sweet, handsome, supportive guy, as long as
you’re able to satisfy your
every impulsive desire.
A movie so generic, yet inexplicably popular,
it’s basically the Olive Garden of Love
Stories.
And a romance that will make nagging girlfriends
ask “Why aren’t you more like Ryan Gosling?”
Prompting all boyfriends to ask: “Can we
please watch Die Hard?
Prepare to relive the bad driving,
the violence,
the shirtless-ness,
the red dresses,
the more shirtless-ness,
the horrible slurping,
and the death of feminism.
Starring...
Perfection
Rachel McAdam’s Apple
Newsies
Julia Stiles
Joseph Stalin
Fancy Cyclops
James Garnish
and...
an old lady
The Movie Your Girlfriend Will Make You Watch
So wait, he wrote hundreds of letters, but
couldn’t just call her once?
Ugh could have saved me 2 hours.
Thanks for watching!
Be sure to subscribe and be sure to tell us
in the comments below what movie you want
to see next.
And tell me what words you'd like to hear
me say in my epic movie trailer voice.